what I do know about Hawaii that there
was a queen you know that's as far as a
gun through me I grew up in Hawaii I
went to an AA Hawaiian school I'm a
delightfully I went to a school that
only love flying I grew up in Honolulu I
don't claim to know anything about
Hawaiian history
I don't remember learning any Hawaiian
history back at school
really I don't except Pearl Harbor being
that I don't know anything and I'm
pretty sure I'm not gonna do the best
I'm kind of excited to see it how much
they actually remember let's go take
this test we're the first people to
arrive in Hawaii a Polynesian be
Tahitian see American I know someone
from fifth harmony that's Polynesian
what do you think you asked me for what
the answer yeah no I definitely know I
think Polynesian I guess Polynesian I
said a Polynesians Polynesian oh yay
nice oh cool good for the last king of
Hawaii a David Kelly Kawa be Kamehameha
the great see Cesare Kahlua
ekoo Komaki a Hawkeye kahan Aquila Kappa
a Kia and D Steve I mean there's only
one that sounds right I'm saying David
Kalakaua nice yeah that's what I put
down a David Clarke oh wow okay
Hawaii's last king was forced to sign
away the executive powers of the
monarchy who took over power immediately
after him aid the people of Hawaii be US
businessman see the people of Kona D the
US government Oh God I think it's the US
government for the US government yeah so
I put time I put a US businessman a US
businessman yes I mean it doesn't
surprise me I feel like business
have as much or more power than the
government in our country they held my
economy so money talks I guess I feel
really bad I didn't even know that in
the 1890s Hawaii's last ruler Queen
Liliuokalani was a imprisoned be forced
to abdicate sea stripped of her power
illegally D all of the above fourth to
abdicate I'm just completely guessing at
this point I'm gonna say all of the
above I think Missy all the above D you
guess all the above
she was imprisoned in her own palace
it's like someone going into your house
and just being like can't do anything
here got in your room and stay there
after the overthrow of the Hawaiian
Kingdom in 1893 which of these were Ben
hey speaking Hawaiian in school B
consumption of Hawaiian dishes C
planting of Hawaiian flowers or D all of
the above I mean is it a lie I
definitely think it's a I put a speaking
Hawaiian in school shame okay my grandma
she didn't really get to speak Hawaiian
she didn't really know about like some
of the wine traditions and everything in
a culture where history and information
is passed down you know through word of
mouth bye you know racing the language I
mean you you erase the memory which of
Jesus believed to be a reason why Kula
dancing was banned a hula made Hawaiians
lazy and unwilling to work be hula
threatened the ability to convert people
to Christianity and was therefore evil
see it was a heathen practice for
physical pleasure D all of the above
this is ridiculous I can't believe it
was even banned I feel like it's Holly
by pony above
I think it's hula Thor in the ability to
convert people to Christianity I put the
same one goes oh damn it I grew up
dancing hula dancing Tahitian I can't
imagine not having it in my life
after the attack on Pearl Harbor how did
the u.s. use the Hawaiian Islands to
prepare for the war hey hiding missiles
within Hawaiian water supplies be
placing a specific tax on Hawaiians to
pay for weapons see using one of the
islands as a bombing range D putting
underaged Hawaiians into the army this
one's hard
no all the above for this one which I
feel like wouldn't be crazy
I'm guessing it's either water supply or
like using an Eileen s bombing range
I put bcn
see using an island as a bombing range
you can't really get to the island
unless you go through a certain
organization because otherwise you might
trigger a bomb that hasn't exploded yet
this test is a hard test it's also like
exciting to get it right but then it's
like oh [ __ ] like this is really sad
when did Hawaii officially receive an
apology from the US government for its
role in starting the coop a 50 years
after the coup B immediately after their
statehood see after US military bases
left D a hundred years after the coup I
don't know because I don't remember
there being an apology maybe a hundred
years I think it's a D yeah I think it's
D as well its first 100 years just 1993
Bill Clinton signing a formal apology to
our kingdom they feel like it's okay to
just give them that credit and then they
can move on but give people their stuff
back on July 12 1898 the u.s. formally
annexed Hawaii
however international law dictates that
annexation treaties must be signed by
both countries involved this did not
occur in Hawaii given this information
is Hawaii estates to be technical Hawaii
is a illegal occupation these are like
you know laws that Hawaii never agreed
to in the first place as far as being a
state I don't think it is a state just
because of international law that is
still kind of disputed to the state in
other course varying attitudes but I
mean yeah the fact of the matter is the
u.s. took Hawaii and call it a state so
it was a cool test I like that it
highlights these issues but I feel like
this was an American history test on the
subject of Hawaii rather than a you know
a Hawaiian history test I learned so
much today I think how we view Hawaii in
America is just like a vacation paradise
if we learned this in school we would be
in a different frame of mind everyone
should understand what land they're
visiting and where they're building
things on I knew a lot of the facts I'm
going to Hawaiian school but I didn't
really know the full context this was
really enlightening it's really nice to
learn all this stuff and I definitely
would want to learn more
about Hawaii before the US and I wish
that I'd like sought out this
information earlier